j'en ai une autre un peu pourri dans le
genre dans le le Palais des Festivals là
où on déjeune où j'ai de trac et de
nervosité tellement j'adore Jennifer
Lawrence on s'est présenté l'un à
l'autre les présentations étaient
catastrophiques entre deux plats avec
des gens qui ont mal introduit donc elle
a pas du tout compris qu'est-ce que je
faisais dans la vie pourquoi je voulais
la saluer elle était avec d'autres gens
tout était kata et on s'est serré le dos
de la main comme ça tellement on était
nerveux ah nice to meet you et tout bah
on était nerveux j'étais nerveux elle a
été nerveuse de bon c'est qui ce mec qui
débarque pendant mon déjeuner donc la
dernière fois que j'ai touché Jennifer
Lawrence c'était le dos de sa main avec
le dos de ma main et ça n'a jamais été
rectifié et et j'en fais encore des
cauchemars
et elle ah thank you ok